a juror from Bill Cosby's trial told CBS
News there were concerns that politics
may have played a role in taking the
actor to court
the juror former Marine and longtime
Pennsylvania resident asked to remain
anonymous
he said the mood inside the deliberation
room was very very tense lots of Tears
lots of emotions Jericka Duncan spoke to
some of the jurors she's in Pittsburgh
tarika good morning good morning this
was such a high-profile case that the
jurors were selected from the Pittsburgh
area and in fact Norristown which is
where the trial was held is over four
hours from here now the juror who spoke
to a local reporter first told me
off-camera he wouldn't say whether or
not he thought Bill Cosby was innocent
or guilty but he had a lot to say when
asked about the allegations he openly
admitted he gave him pillows almost
incriminating himself a very very honest
from his side you could believe from his
testimony what he did but not from her
speaking to The Associated Press under a
condition of anonymity the male juror
praised Bill Cosby for his honesty
during a 2005 deposition but the juror
was suspicious of andrea constand the
Canadian woman who says Cosby drugged
and molested her in 2004 mr. Cosby
invited to his home and she arrives in a
bare midriff with incense and bathtubs
that's a question but when asked about
the decision to reopen the 2005 case
against Cosby he suggests the motivation
may have been political there was no new
evidence nothing just the statute of
limitations were running out did that
really bother you yes it does
I think they created this whole thing a
case that was settled in o5 and we had
to bring it up again at 17 the juror
told CBS News that during deliberations
the group of seven men and five women
ain't almost evenly divided in their
positions but after a marathon 52 hours
the jury told the judge it was
hopelessly deadlocked on all three
counts he was so adamant in warning a
unanimous decision he wanted at a
decision and we were thinking he was
going to send us back now another juror
I spoke to who's a husband and father
said this process was without a doubt
challenging but he said he along with
other jurors had made an agreement not
to talk about the details of the
deliberations as to not taint the next
jury which is expected to hear this case
in the coming months Nora
all right tarika thank you so much